the next movie to get the latest yep saw
some articles online with the title same
venom gets a new release date and a new
title I don't have the actual
information on both so I thought it's
only fitting that we react to the cosmic
Wonders video Yeah right this time I
don't want to wake up next year and be
like where's Lou
what's funny about that whole venom to
situation where like the trailer
supposed to come out did it then we did
a video with Warren I think most people
picked up on that it was a joke but
there was a lot of people a lot
especially on social media who were a
attacking us while talking to Warren
being like why were they so mean and be
attacking us personally going there was
no reason to be that mean of Loren has
incredibly low self-esteem and he was
like you know what just put the video up
and I want people to see thing was
outlined there it was taking the piss
out of it all right yeah I don't know
what the actual title is yet I thought
was gonna be maximum carnage that just
sounded cool no it's gonna be homecoming
yeah
far from Levi's gurmann coming into the
movie finally leave your home
oh yeah and congratulations on finally
hitting 550 thousand subscribers Warren
do we win the PlayStation how's it going
everybody it's warm welcome back to my
channel to cosmic wonder where we talk
about all things Marvel and today we
have some venom 2 news some great news
and unfortunately some bad news as well
as venom has officially been pushed back
as no longer going to be hitting
theaters on October 2nd of 2020 surprise
surprises in theaters on June 25th of
2021 that's exactly this interesting
statement push the release date soon
birthday to me as I mentioned we do have
some good news because the official
title for venom 2 has been reviewing
this is this report comes from
variety.com and they're the ones who
broke the report about venom being
pushed back to next year and their
articles oxide saying Sony's venom
sequel officially titled venom
let there be carnage but they've already
titled a comic run back to the movie
that's everybody's main question as well
sadly this definitely pushes the trailer
release date back a bit sadly a lot a
couple of months at the very least
because June of 2021 is over a year away
so as far as a teaser trailer for venom
let there be carnage is concerned we
probably won't see any until at least
we're within a year of the movie coming
out and this is why Sony did not refer
the data make more they were unsure of
whether or not they were so that twice
to post but no cuz this year okay the
trailer X to a later date which they
officially have so very sad but also
awesome news that we finally know the
official title for venom 2 venom let
there be carnage what do you think about
this title look I think happy birthday
to Joe I'm - a happy birthday Joe - and
of course Marvel you can follow me on
Twitter for live updates and as always
thank you so much for watching woof woof
all right there we go well let's talk
about that title really fast I love it
I mean maximum carnage sounded like a
cool title let them eat carnage let
there be carnage I think is also a
really fun title accepting meaning a bit
more into kind of the goofiness of the
first venom did because if you guys
remember the marketing for that first
venom film they try to make it look like
this heavy intense action picture and
then there ended up being a lot more
humor and cheesiness to it than we've
come to expect granted I would still
like venom to especially under any
surface this direction to implement a
little bit more intensity like some
genuine it may be horror but just a
little bit of either you got carnage in
there Woody Harrelson filling in the
shoes for carnage I just think that
would absolutely work that being said
let there be carnage there's something
that feels like so throwback II about
that whole title I you know exactly it
almost reminds me of the tagline from
saw to just like oh yes there will be
blood it's like a promise area but
that's what I love about what you're
saying is that it feels like a tagline
doesn't really feel like a sequel title
exactly yeah yeah which is nice because
in a time where everything or a lot of
movies get subtitles I honestly don't
tend to like them and this is one
instance where I'm like that's perfect
and it also gets you hyped up to see the
character carnage it's an introductory
timeline and it makes me wonder too I
mean like we said with Annie Circus like
his Mowgli movies a lot darker and
edgier then say the Jungle Book remake
and so in a sense that still gives me
hope that even if this is rated pg-13
he's still gonna bring some of that like
heavy metal savagery because like
maximum carnage makes me think of heavy
metal and carnage it's already kind of a
heavy metal character but yeah I doubt
this would be rated R but I don't have
that hope of like maybe we can push that
envelope because carnage like is a
terrifying savage just like
uncontainable character well I mean of a
pg-13 you could really push the lines
with violence but you can't push it with
like sexual content but that won't be
that won't be necessary for this one's
let there be car Angela clearly they can
still change the title down the road
like carnage rain like carnage bee venom
carnage and the fantabulous emancipation
of venom we just spin off into any
brought just working for the day and
then as far as this new release date
goes honestly that's a
little bit of a baffling release date to
me because it was such a box-office
juggernaut that's another reason why I
know it won't be ready because this is
such a huge hit when it came out in
October saying let there be carnage
gives an implication that it's leaning a
little bit more into some type of horror
aesthetic to say the least
October just seems like a perfect
release date to do it venom to me just
doesn't read like a June release date
I'm sure it'll still make all the money
it's gonna make and February is when the
Eternals comes out in 2021 Morbius comes
out in March
then shang-chi in May and venom 2 in
June and then Doctor Strange in November
you're jamming these Sony Marvel films
in in-between the MCU movies so I guess
that strategy fits and I'm sure that a
lot of these Studios probably readjusted
a lot of their release schedules kind of
around what Disney is actually doing
though I'm sure I mean I wouldn't have
my waiting a little bit longer till
October but I know there's some camera
which movies right off the dome I
believe Batman is getting released in
October that fits really well so I guess
yeah I mean if Batman already took the
slot it just makes it seems like with
venom - it was a little bit strange that
Sony announced all these release dates
being pushed but they didn't include
venom - in that I think that's because
this is their most precious that they
know will make a lot of money
because more bees are like we're still
not a hundred percent sure there's
ghostbusters after life but with venom -
that's a guaranteed hint we just need to
make sure we're putting it at the right
time especially post pandemic you know
like when people are able to go out we
want to make sure we're reaping as much
profit as possible so as weird as it
seems for me for venom to to come out in
June I guess business-wise that makes
the most sense hopefully venom three
goes detective yeah cuz it is perfect
for that and I feel like they'd have
more legs during that time and they
wouldn't get swept away by a bunch of
other summer flicks you know right right
what do you think of this venom - title
give any opinion towards the release
they know I feel like most people don't
feel that it's kind of accept it for
what it is
people are so amped to get the
yeah well make sure to subscribe at the
cosmic Wonder thanks for putting this
together you're a total jerk I hate you
in my whole life subscribe to the real
rejects make sure to click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever we got a new YouTube video up
or else so got a discord now thanks to
John Humphrey over here last but not
least I send this with a peat dawn and
katie-ann I thought I'd be fun for this
month that for our page from the day
shoutouts we read some fan fiction for a
lot of our patrons of what if these two
met each other one day and I chose for
this one
Pete Don and katie-ann both people who
love to dabble in writing I'll be
playing Pete dawn he'll be playing Katy
an interior coffee shop afternoon Pete
dawn a handsome man with presumably
massive genitals sits on his laptop
weight sits in front of his laptop when
his eye catches a beautiful sexy funny
magnetic woman named Katie Ann who
presumably has massive genitals Pete dog
gathers the courage picks up his laptop
and crosses over to Katie Ann mind if I
sit and that's bold of you I don't meet
many men with that level of courage at a
Starbucks or coffee bean thanks I've
been doing a lot of personal development
lately so I figured I should give it a
shot Pete takes a seat across from her
you're quite revealing with your
expositional dialog say you have a
laptop in front of you are you a writer
in fact I am I write a lot of fan
fiction currently working on thirteen
novels this year and I work out how
about yourself I dabble what does that
mean dabble means to immerse one's hands
or feet partially in water then move
them around gently ie they dabbled their
feet in the rock pools oh I didn't
realize you're gonna give me the actual
definition of what it meant to dabble
I'm sorry I'm I'm great with my words
and have a wide range of vocabulary
vocabulary meaning the body of words
used in a particular language wow you
really are a writer I'm Katie
I'm Pete wait that's all right
I'm Pete I meant I dabble in writing I
read a lot of poetry a great one I must
say have you heard of Greg Alba
oh yeah he's that youtuber with massive
genitals yeah yeah he likes to write
about massive general - yeah he likes to
write about massive genitals a lot -
he's a
big fan of my work you know you remind
me of my mother
I like that compliment because I'm very
close with my mom speaking of mothers
I'm working on a story about Pamela
Voorhees Jason's mother from Friday the
13th oh yes I relate with that character
quite a lot you do I'm kidding I have a
dark sense of humor and many sweaters
Greg is still unsure whether or not if I
have a dark sense of humor when he wrote
this hence the lack of back and forth
here that could lead to some additional
chemistry yeah I think my mother liked
cloudy's have made me a great teacher
oh really what do you teach Greg doesn't
remember say I could use your help with
writing this story what's it about it's
a fan fiction story about two patrons
from the real rejects who met in a
coffee shop one day and have instant
chemistry
Pete slides a laptop over her and she
quickly reads it it doesn't sound very
good
now the dialogue is terrible and Greg
could have done a lot more research just
having a hard time thinking of a proper
ending Pete leaves the table the Battle
of Dragon and never sees Katie again
the end
you